สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนเช่น
กันค่ะขอต้อนรับนะคะนักเรียนทุกคนสู่ห้อง
เรียน comprehensible  Thai ห้องเรียน
ภาษาไทยด้วยการฟังค่ะค่ะวันนี้ก็มาพบกับ
ครูบีแล้วก็ครูชินะคะเรามาเจอกันในวัน
อะไรคะวันนี้ครูชิวันนี้วันพฤหัสสบดีค่ะ
ครูบีค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 30 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะครูชิเดือนพฤศจิกายนค่ะอ่า
เดือนนี้เป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือน
ที่ 11 ค่ะอ่าแล้วปีพ.ศอะไรคะปี
พุทธศักราช
2566 ค่ะค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะค.ศหรือคิดพ
ศักราช
2023 ค่ะอืวันนี้เรา 2 คนมาเจอกันในวัน
พฤหัสสบดีค่ะอืมวันพฤหัสสบดีเนี่ยวัน
เนี้ยเป็นวันดีนะคะคนไทยเ่ะมีความเชื่อ
ว่าวันพฤหัสสบดีเนี่ยเหมือนเป็นวันครูค่ะ
พะกเราเนี่ยจะไหว้ครูอือ้านะคะเพราะ
ฉะนั้นคนไทยกับวันแล้วก็มีความเชื่อ
เรื่องต่างๆเนาะใช่แล้วก็ที่สำคัญเนี่ยคน
ไทยเนี่ยเวลาเกิดอวดอวใช่มั้ยคุณแม่เนี่ย
คุณแม่ต้องแต่งงานก่อนนะแตนแทนแนแทนอ่ะ
แต่งงานโรแมนติกกับคุณพ่อแล้วคุณแม่ก็
ท้องแล้วก็มีลูกใช่มั้ยเกิดมาเนี่ยคนไทย
ต้องรู้วันเกิดนะ
คะใช่ค่ะต้องรู้ค่ะว่าเกิดวันอะไรเอวัน
เกิดรู้ด้วยว่าวันที่เท่าไหร่
โอเคนักเรียนบอกเอ๊ะทุกคนก็ต้องรู้วัน
เกิดตัวเองอ๋อไม่ใช่ครูบีหมายถึงว่าวัน
เกิดเนี่ยวันอะไรอืวันจันทร์วันอะไรไม่
ใช่วันที่เท่าไหร่ใช่มั้ยวันที่เท่าไหร่
เนี่ยทุกคนรู้แน่ๆแต่วันอะไรเนี่ยบางคน
รู้บางคนไม่รู้ใช่ค่ะงั้นครูบีถามแล้วกัน
ครูชิเเกิดวันอะไรคะค่ะครูชี้เนี่ยต้องมา
ที่ 1 ค่ะต้องเกิดวันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
อื้อหือวันอาทิตย์รู้วันเกิดมยคะวันที่
เท่าไหร่รู้ค่ะเกิดวันที่ 30 ค่ะมิุอัน
นี้ทุกคนต้องรู้เ้าครูบีนึกว่า 30
พฤศจิกายนไม่ใช่ 30 พฤศจิกายนนะคะ 30
มิถุนายนอืมนะอันนี้วันเกิดครูชิค่ะแล้ว
ครูบีล่ะคะเกิดวันอะไรครูบีเเนี่ยเกิดวัน
อังคารค่ะครูบีเกิดวันอังคารค่ะ
อืมเห็นมั้ยคนไทยเนี่ยก็จะรู้วันเกิดของ
ตัวเองว่าเกิดวันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธ
วันพฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
อ่าแต่เราไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนน่ะรู้วันเกิด
ของตัวเองหรือเปล่าว่าเกิดวันอะไรนะคะแต่
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะกูชิตอนนี้เช็คใน google.com
ได้นะคะอือ้อ้เหรอคะใช่ทุกคนจะรู้แน่ๆนะ
คะว่าใครเกิดวันอาทิตย์วันจันทร์วัน
อังคารวันพุธวันพฤหัสสบดีวันศุกร์วัน
เสาร์อืนะแล้วครูบีถามวันเกิดครูชิทำไมคะ
เอ้าก็อยากถามครูชิไงคะเพราะว่าวันเกิด
เนี่ยคนไทยเนี่ยนอกจากจะไปทำบุญที่วัดใช่
มั้ยคะจัดงานปาร์ตี้อาจจะมีเค้กแล้วก็
เป่า
เค้กร้องเพลง Happy  Birthday ใช่มยแต่คน
ไทยเนี่ยก็ยังมีแบบไปทำบุญอย่างอื่นไงคะ
ครูชิ
อ้ามีทำอย่างอื่นเอ๊เนิยมทำอะไรนะนอกจาก
มีปาร์ตี้มีกินอาหารกันมีเต้นรำนะคะ
อทำบุญแล้วมีอะไรอีกอ่ะเอ้าครูชิคิดว่า
ครูชิก็ต้องเคยทำนะครูชิเคยไปที่วัดเวลา
มีวันเกิดของครูชิมั้ยหรือว่าอยู่ที่บ้าน
แล้วก็มีพระเดินมาบิณฑบาตครูชิอาจจะทำบุญ
มีอาหารแล้วก็ตักบาตรใส่อาหารให้พระอัน
นี้เคยเนาะทำที่บ้านใช่มแล้วเคยไปที่วัด
มั้ยคะในวันเกิดเคยเอ่อไปที่วัดในวันเกิด
เนี่ยเอาเอาของใช้เนี่ยไปไปให้กับพระค่ะ
นะวัดไทยนะคะอ่านี่ครูชิก็อาจจะไปที่วัด
แบบเนี้ยแล้วก็มีของใช่มยเห็นมั้ยคะอัน
นี้ก็จะมีสิ่งของแบบนี้แบบตรงเนี้ยครูบี
ใช่ครูชิก็เอาสังฆทานค่ะอืมสังขะก็คือพระ
สงฆ์เนี่ยของใช้ที่พระสงฆ์ใช้แปลงสีฟันยา
สีฟันสบู่ใช่มั้ยสำหรับที่พระสงฆ์จะต้อง
ใช้เนี่ยก็ใส่ห่อสวยๆนะแล้วก็ไปถวายถวาย
ก็คือให้ให้พระออก็ไปที่วัดแบบนี้ใช่มั้ย
ครูชิเเนี่ยเคยไปทำบุญที่วัดในวันเกิดนอก
จากทำบุญเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยครูชิเห็นมั้ยคะ
เนี่ยเขาจะ
มีถังถังเอ้ยทำไมมีหลายถังยังคะออก็บางคน
เนี่ยเวลาวันเกิด Happy  Birthday  to  Me
มีเนี่ยนะคะหรือ to  you เนี่ยนะคะอ่าบาง
คนเนี่ยเา้าไปทำบุญที่วัดอาจจะเอาของใช้
ใช่มั้ยคะอ่าไปถวายให้กับพระเนาะสบู่แปลง
สีฟันอ่าทิชชู่หรือว่าาจะเป็นอาหารพวก
กาแฟเนาะ 3  in  one อย่างเงี้ยค่ะเอออก็
ไปถวายพระเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยเห็นมั้ยูชิเขาก็
จะมีอะไรอยู่ในเค้าดูอะไรอยู่ในถังคะ
มันมีสัตว์ค่ะูชิอ้าเหรอูชินึกว่าดูอะไร
ในถังมีอะไรสน
ใจเพราะว่าในถังเนี่ยเขาจะมีสัตว์ที่จะ
เอาไปปล่อยที่แม่น้ำค่ะ
โอ้เอาไปปล่อยที่แม่น้ำใชู่ชิ้วเนี่ยเคย
เคยปล่อยค่ะแต่ปล่อยนกมีกมเล็กๆแล้วก็
เปิดไปไปๆอือ๋อเป็นนกใช่มคะครูชิใช่ค่ะ
เป็นนกก็จะเป็นแบบกรงเล็กๆเนมีกงเล็กๆแบบ
นี้นะแล้วก็มีนกนะมีนกหลายๆตัวนะแต่เป็น
นกตัวเล็กๆครูบีนะมีประมาณ 5-7 ตัวแล้ว
แต่กงนะแล้วก็มีที่เปิดครูชิก็จะเปิดตรง
นี้นกก็บินไปค่ะแบบนี้มยครูชิใช่ค่ะครูบี
นะคะได้แต่ปล่อยนกค่ะอืปล่อยานิดหน่อย
ปล่อยนกมากๆอ่านะครูชิน่ะก็ไปปล่อยนกอ่า
ในวันเกิดนะนกก็จะได้บินเป็นอิสระนะไม่
ตายเนานกก็จะได้มีชีวิตแล้วก็ออกไปอยู่
กับธรรมชาตินะอื
อ๋อส่วนมากปล่อยนกนกแต่ในถังที่ครูชิเห็น
เมื่อกี้นะคะค่ะเขาไม่ได้ปล่อยนกค่ะครูชิ
เออถ้าเป็นนกมันต้องอยู่ในกรงไงในถัง
เนี่ยมันต้องมีอะไรแน่ๆเลยในถังเนี่ยมี
ปลาค่ะแล้วในวัดเห็นมั้ยวัดในประเทศไทย
มากๆเนี่ยก็จะมีเอ่อมีท่าน้ำเนาะแบบนี้นะ
คะใช่
อืนะคะก็ในในวัดนะคะก็จะมีท่าน้ำเนาะอัน
นี้ก็จะไปปล่อยปลาเนี่ยค่ะูชิ
โอ้โหอันนี้ปลาช่อนนะปลาช่อนอปลาช่อนอูชิ
เคยปล่อยปปปลมีเยอะเออปลาระช่อนเนี่ยไม่
ได้เคยปล่อยแต่เคยปล่อยแบบปลาปลาเหมือนงู
อ่ะปลาไหลเออครูชิเเนี่ยเคยปล่อยเป็นปลา
ไหลนะนะคะใช่ค่ะจริงๆปลามีหลายอย่างมาก
เนาะูชิ
ใช่ค่ะก็มีคนบอกูชิค่ะว่าถ้าเกิดูชิจะไป
ปล่อยปลาเนี่ยูชิต้องไปปล่อยปลาทีู่ชิอ่ะ
ไม่กิน
อืมเพราะว่าบางทีครูชิเเนี่ยอาจจะช่วยมัน
แล้วก็ปล่อยไปเสร็จแล้วูชิก็มากินมันอีก
ทีเนี่ยอันเนี้ยก็ไม่ดีใช่มั้ยเค้าก็กลัว
ว่าไปกินปลาตัวที่เราปล่อยไงอเราแบบให้
เขาคพาโชคไม่ดีไปแล้วเนี่ยแล้วเราไปกิน
เ้าอีกนะคอ๋อเพราะว่าปลาไหลเนี่ยปลาไหล
เนี่ยจะตัวยาวๆเนาะแบบนี้เลยค่ะครูชิเ
เนี่ยปล่อยปลาไหลออก็ไม่กินปลาไหลอยู่
แล้วใช่มยใช่ค่ะูชิก็เลือกปลาทีู่ชิไม่
กินเพราะว่าถ้าปลาที่กินเนี่ยเราก็กลัวไง
กลัวว่าเวลาที่เราไปซื้อปลาที่เรากิน
เนี่ยมันจะเจอตัวที่เราไป
ปล่อย
เหมือนกับช่วยแล้วช่วยไม่จริงไงปล่อยไป
เสร็จแล้ว 1 วันก็เอามากินออืแล้วปลาไหล
เนี่ยครูชิเกิดวันอาทิตย์ใช่มั้ยคนไทยเ้า
ก็มีความเชื่อนะครูชิใช่มีความเชื่ออะไร
คะเอ้าเกิดวันอาทิตย์เนี่ยต้องปล่อยปลา
เนี่ยกี่ตัวอ๋อเหรอคะแล้ววันอาทิตย์เนี่ย
ต้องปล่อยปลากี่ตัวคะวันอาทิตย์เนี่ยต้อง
ปล่อยปลาเนี่ย 6 ตัวค่ะแล้วจะโชคดีอืต้อง
6 ตัวอืนะอย่าโอเค่ะ 6 ตัวโอเค 6 ตัว
โอเคใช่มั้ยไม่แพงครูชิก็ไปที่ตลาดนะไป
ซื้อปลาที่ตลาดดีกว่าเพราะว่าที่ตลาดก็จะ
มีปลาที่แบบว่ายังไม่ตายใช่มั้ยกูชิก็ไป
ซื้อปลาไหลค่ะอือืไปซื้อปลาไหลที่ตตลาดนะ
เพราะว่าเราคิดว่าอันเนี้ยเราได้ช่วยปลา
จริงๆถูกมั้ยเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดเราไม่ไปซื้อ
นะจะมีคนซื้อแล้วคนก็อาจจะไปทำอาหารปลา
ไหลผัดเผ็ดนะก็ไปซื้อปลาที่ตลาดนะคะแล้ว
ก็เดี๋ยวเา้าเนี่ยก็จะเอาปลาเนี่ยอ่าปลา
ไหลเนี่ยก็คือว่าใส่ถุง
อืเอาปลาไหลใส่งให้เราอ่าใช่นะเอาปลาไหล
เนี่ยใส่ถุงให้เราเสร็จแล้วูชิเนี่ยก็เอา
ไปปล่อยที่แม่น้ำอย่างเงี้ยค่ะอืนะเพราะ
ว่าที่ตลาดเนี่ยจะมีปลาให้เลือกมากๆแต่
ูชิคือไม่กินปลาไหลไงูชิก็ไปปล่อยปลาไหล
แล้วปลาเนี่ย 6 ตัวครูวีว่าก็โอเคนะเกิด
วันอาทิตย์นะคะนี่ปลาไหลนะเขาคก็จะใส่ถุง
แบบเนี้ยค่ะอ่าอ้าปลายังไม่ตายเห็นมั้ยคะ
ออ่าครูชิก็ปล่อยให้ปลาเนี่ยมีชีวิตนะเอา
ไปปล่อยที่แม่น้ำงี้ค่ะอเพราะว่าถ้าเกิด
ครูชิเเนี่ยไม่ไปซื้อเนี่ยเดี๋ยวปลาไหล
ตรงเเดี๋ยวก็จะมีคนเนี่ยมาซื้อแล้วก็ไปไป
ฆ่ามันใช่มั้ยแล้วครูชินี่ซื้อมาก่อนแล้ว
ก็ไปปล่อยมันเนี่ยมันก็โอโชคดีวันนี้ฉัน
ไม่ตายใช่มั้ยอืถูกต้องค่ะูชิแล้วปลาไหล
เนี่ยเขาก็มีความเชื่อเนาะคนไทยอ่าอูชิ
รู้มั้ยคะปล่อยปลาไหลเนี่ยคนไทยเชื่อว่า
มันดียังไงจะโชคดีอะไรอืครูชิเนี่ยมีความ
รู้เรื่องการปล่อยปลลามีความหมายอะไรค่ะ
ดีมากค่ะงั้นครูบีถามครูชิเลยแล้วกัน
ปล่อยปลาไหลเนี่ยดียังไงคะเอออ่าเพราะว่า
ครูชิเนี่ยไปถามคนที่ขายปลาที่วัดเพื่อ
ให้ปล่อยเนี่ยูชิบอกอ้าทำไมมีปลาหลายๆ
อย่างคะเ้าบอกว่าปลาแต่ละอย่างเนี่ยมี
ความหมายไม่เหมือนกันครูบีอย่างปลาไหลที่
ครูชิปล่อยเนี่ยจะหมายถึงเรื่องเกี่ยวกับ
การเงินอืเกี่ยวกับเรื่องงานเกี่ยวกับ
เรื่องเรียนอันนี้จะราบรื่นไม่มีปัญหาค่ะ
ออเรื่องเงินก็จะมีเงินใช้จ่ายนะคะอือ่า
เรื่องเรียนก็ไม่มีปัญหาเรื่องการทำงานก็
จะทำงานแบบดีมากไม่มีปัญหากับ
ออฟฟิศใช่พอเราบอกว่าราบรื่นเนี่ยมัน
เหมือนกับเวลาเรามีเงินใช่มั้ยเงินก็มา
เรื่อยๆเรื่อยๆเรื่อยๆเรื่อยๆเรื่อยๆไม่
มีแบบว่ามาหยุดไม่มีหยุดไม่เอ่อไม่มี
สะดุดค่ะไปเรื่อยๆเงินมาเรื่อยๆการงานก็
ดีไปเรื่อยๆค่ะไม่มีแบบมีงานตกงานมีมีงาน
ตกงานอันนี้ไม่ราบรื่นออเข้าใจแล้วกูชิ
เพราะว่าปลาไหล
เนี่ยไม่ใช่ทุกคนจะจับได้นะครูชิอ่ะเห็น
มั้ยปลาไหลเนี่ยเวลาเราจับเนี่ยมันก็
จะมันรื่นมันรื่นค่ะมันรื่นไปอ่าึจับ
เนี่ยโอ้โหจับไม่อยู่ค่ะต้องเก่งจริงๆ
ต้องมีเทคนิคนะคะอ่าอันนี้คือปลาไหลเนาะ
คุณชิก็บอกว่าเข้าใจว่าถ้าเราเนี่ยอยากทำ
งานแล้วก็ราบรื่นไม่มีปัญหาเรื่องเงินไม่
มีปัญหาก็ปล่อยปลาไหลอันนี้เป็นความเชื่อ
แบบคนไทยนะคะอันนี้คือปลาไหลนะอ่ะแล้วมี
ปลาอย่างอื่นมั้ยคะที่ครูชิรู้ความหมาย
ว่าปล่อยแล้วมันจะดีโชคดีเกี่ยวกับอะไร
ปลาหมอ
ค่ะปลามีปลาหมอด้วยใช่ปลาด็อกเตอร์เหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะมีปลาหมอมีปลาพยาบาลด้วยนะอ่ะจริง
อ่ะจริงปลาพยาบาลชอบอยู่กับ
ฉลามนะคะจะอยู่ฉลามใช่มั้แล้วก็มีปลาตัว
เล็กๆแล้วก็ชอบกินอาหารให้กับฉลาม
อันเนี้ยปลาพยาบาลแต่ปลาหมอชื่อก็บอกแล้ว
ไงว่าเป็นหมออืมเดี๋ยวต้องไปดูก่อนค่ะ
กูชิปลาหมอก็จะหน้าตาเป็นแบบนี้เนาะ
เดี๋ยวครูบีเปิดภาพนี้แล้วกันมันสวยดีนะ
มันชัดดีนี่ปลาหมอจริงๆปลาหมอเป็นปลาที่
อร่อยมากนะูชิ
เอ้าเหรอคะใชู่ชิเนี่ยคิดว่าปลาหมอมันตัว
เล็กไงน่าจะไม่อร่อยเพราะมีก้างไงนัก
เรียนก้างอ่ะก้างปลาอืก้าง
ปลาเนาคิดว่ามีก้างปลาเยอะไงอือูชิก็เลย
คิดว่าจะไม่อร่อยใช่มยใช่นะแต่อร่อยคะ
อร่อยค่ะูชิอ่ะเดี๋ยวให้ดูคือปลาหมอเนี่ย
มันก็จะมีขนาดหลายๆอย่างเนาะตัวเล็กๆอ่า
ตัวขนาดกลางแล้วก็ขนาดใหญ่นะปลาหมอเป็น
ปลาที่อร่อยมากูชิ
อืแต่ว่าก้างมันจะแข็งนะแล้วก็อันตรายนะ
เนี่ยอันนี้ก็จะไซสประมาณแบบเอ่อประมาณ
เท่ามือครูบีนะออ่าครูบีถ้าอันเนี้ยอัน
นี้เป็นเป็นปลาหมอเทศใช่มั้ยอือปลาหมอมัน
ก็มีหลายแบบอืปลาใช่นะนะคะถ้าปลาหมอเทศ
เนี่ยเนื้อจะเยอะนะอร่อยค่ะแต่ถ้าปลาหมอ
ไทยตัวมันจะเล็กๆเหมือนปลากระดี่เลยอ่ะ
ตัวเล็กมาออืนะก็บางคนก็ชอบกินเนาะแต่บาง
คนอาจจะบอกไม่ชอบเพราะมันมีก้างเยอะนะคะ
อ่าอันนี้ปลาหมอแปลว่าปลาชนิดนี้น่ะ iqd
ใช่มั้ย
คะกินแล้วคือไม่ไม่ใช่กินปล่อยแล้วจะแบบ
ไอคิวดีไม่ใช่ครูบีอันเนี้ยความหมายก็คือ
ว่าปล่อยปลาหมอเนี่ยจะทำให้สุขภาพแข็งแรง
อนะคะโควิดไม่มาค่ะอืไวรัสแบคทีเรียมา
เนี่ยสู้ได้หมดนอจะโชคดีเกี่ยวกับสุขภาพ
มีโรคไม่มีโรคโควิดไม่มีโรคอะไรใช่มั้ยคะ
ใช่ค่ะอันนี้จะทำให้สุขภาพแข็งแรง
ก็ใครอยากสุขภาพแข็งแรงก็ซื้อปลาหมอแล้ว
ก็ไปปล่อยนะอ่าใครอยากทั้งสุขภาพแข็งแรง
ทั้งอยากมีเรื่องเงินแบบราบรื่นไม่มี
ปัญหาในการทำงานอ่าการเรียนก็ซื้อปลาหมอ
ด้วยซื้อปลาไหลด้วยนะคะไป
ปล่อยอ่ะปลาอย่างอื่นหรอคะครูชิที่เราจะ
ปล่อยปลากยค่ะปลากรายอือันนี้ได้ปาปลาที่
เราเอามาทอดกินมยอ่ะทอดมันปลากายใช่ปลา
กายเนี่ยหลายๆคนน่ะชอบกินทอดมันปลากาย
เนื้อมันเนื้อมันหนึบๆเหนียวๆอ่อยนะคะปลา
มันจะมีจุดๆๆๆๆอ่ะนะคะมีลายเป็นจุดๆๆนะ
หางปลาเร็วๆออใช่แบบนี้แหละปลากรายอ๋อปลา
กรายเนี่ยแต่ถ้านักเรียนเคยเห็นเวลาเขา
เอาไปทอดเนี่ยนักเรียนจะไม่รู้เนาะว่ามัน
เป็นปลาค่ะนะคะอ่าปรากาย
เนี่ยมีความหมายยังไงอ่ะครูชิคือเสียงมัน
คล้ายๆกับคำว่ากายอืมปกรายกับกายมันคล้าย
ๆกันไงมันเหมือนกับเรื่องที่ไม่ดีเรื่อง
ที่ร้ายๆอ่ะมันจะเปลี่ยนหรือมันจะกลาย
เป็นเรื่องดีๆค่ะ
อืนะอันนี้ก็เป็นความหมายที่ดีเนาะูชิใช่
อจากที่เราอาจจะมีปัญหามีโชคไม่ดีพอเรา
ปล่อยปลลากายนะทุกอย่างมันก็จะเปลี่ยนใช่
มยกลายเป็นเรื่องดีๆอืมให้เราเนี่ยโชคดี
นะคะอ่ะเดี๋ยวถ้าอย่างงั้นเนี่ยต้องถาม
ครูชิก่อนว่าครูชิเเนี่ยชอบกินทอดมันปลา
กายมั้ยคะชอบๆชอบกินทอดมันปลาก่ายเพราะ
ฉะนั้นครูชีไม่ไม่เอาปลากลายไป
ปล่อยอ่านักเรียนอาจจะอยากรู้จักเนาะอ่ะ
ครูบีมีรูปให้ดูเห็นมั้ยคะโอ้โหทอดมันปรา
กยคิดว่าหลายคนเคยกินค่ะอืออร่อยมากค่ะ
ูชินะใช่ค่ะขอน้ำจิ้มด้วยค่ะนี่กินได้
อร่อยด้วยนะเออท่อนมันปากก่ายของเราอ๋อ
ใครที่อยากจะแบบว่าจากที่มีปัญหาอ่าก็รู้
สึกโอไม่มีความสุขแล้วอยากจะให้ปัญหาที่
มันไม่ดีเนี่ยเปลี่ยนกลายเป็นเรื่องดีๆก็
เอาปากายไปปล่อยอืใช่ค่ะนะคะก็เป็นความ
เชื่อนะอาจจะมีเสียงที่มันทำให้รู้สึกไป
ปล่อยแล้วสบายใจโอ๊ยอันนี้โชคไม่ดีเลยทำ
ธุรกิจเนี่ยเงินน่ะหายไม่รู้ว่าจะได้คืน
หรือเปล่าอืใช่มั้ยมีคนเนี่ยเอ่อมีมีคน
เนี่ยเอาเงินไปอนะมีคนเอาเงินไปเนี่ยเรา
จะได้เงินคืนมาหรือเปล่าไม่สบายใจเลยไป
ปล่อยปลาค่ะไปปล่อยปลลากรายนะคะเรื่องที่
ร้ายๆจะกลายเป็นดีพอปล่อยแล้วเดี๋ยวบางที
มีตำรวจโทรมาว่าออเงินที่ของคุณที่ถูก
ขโมยไปได้คืนแล้วเยนะจากที่คิดว่าเงินที่
ถูกขโมยจะไม่ได้คืนก็กลายเป็นว่าได้คืน
ความหมายดี
อันนี้ปลากนะคะมีอีกมคะที่ครูชิรู้มีค่ะ
อันเนี้ยหลายๆคนเห็นเห็นแบบชอบไปปล่อยปลา
ตัวนี้ค่ะปลาดุกอือไม่ใช่ปลาดุนะคะอือัน
นี้ปลาดุกดุกปลาดุกอ้อปลาดุกเนี่ยครูบีก็
ไปปล่อยค่ะครูชินะคะปลาดุกจริงๆแล้วเป็น
ปลาที่นักเรียนจะเห็นว่าคนไทยเนี่ยเอามา
ย่างเอามาทอดเอามาทำอาหารมากๆเนาะยำปลา
ดุกฟูอ่าปลาดุกย่างอย่างเงี้ยจะมีเยอะมาก
นะอันนี้ปลาดลาบปลาดุกอืนะอันนี้ก็เดี๋ยว
ให้ดูรูปนี้เนาอาจจะบางทีมองไม่ชัดนะคะ
ปลาดุกเนี่ยมันจะมีหนวดค่ะเห็นมยเนี่ยมัน
จะมีนักเรียนเรียกปลาแมวปลาแมวเอา
แคสบอกไม่ใช่ปลา
ดุกพอแปลเป็นภาษาไทยนี่ไม่ใช่เลยนะภาษา
ไทยเรียกปลาดุกไม่ใช่ปลาแมวนะอืเพราะมัน
มีหนวดแบบแมวใช่ตรงนี้มันก็จะมีหนวดออกมา
ปลาดุกเนี่ยอร่อยนะคะคนไทยก็กินนะตามตลาด
บางทีเราไปอ่าตลาดแบบคนไทยก็อาจจะเห็นว่า
เขาเอามาย่างเนาะปลดุกย่างนะคะออันนี้คือ
ความหมายเนี่ยดีมั้ยครูชิความหมายดีนะคะ
อันเนี้ย
เหมายถึงเวลาที่เราจะเจออะไรที่โชคไม่ดี
อ่ะโชคร้ายอ่ะแบบเดินๆไปเนี่ยต้นไม้กิ่ง
ไม้หล่นมาตีหัวไปโรงพยาบาลเย็บอนะอีกวัน
เดินออกไปเปิดประตูไปรถเฉี่ยวล้มไปโรง
พยาบาลโอ๊ยอันเนี้ยเขาบอกว่าโชคไม่ดีมี
เคราะห์นะคะต้องไปปล่อยปลาาดุกค่ะอืเป็น
ความเชื่อแบบคนไทยนะคนไทยก็จะป่อดหรือใน
วันเกิดของเราก็ได้นะคะอ่าเราก็อยากปล่อย
ให้แบบอ่าสิ่งไม่ดีออกไปนะก็ปล่อยปลาดุก
ได้นะคะอ่ะมีปลาอย่างอื่นอีกมยกูชิหมด
หรือยังปลามีอีกค่ะนะคะแต่บางทีเราเอาเรา
เอาสัตว์อย่างอื่นบ้างมยได้ๆได้เอาแบบไม่
ปล่อยปลาเพราะอย่างครูชิเูชิบอกว่าวัน
เกิดูชิบางปีูชิก็ปป่อนกใช่มยใช่เพราะว่า
ูชิชอบกินปลาไงก็เลยไม่ค่อยนิยมปปล่อยปลา
เท่าไหร่แตู่ชิอาจจะชอบปล่อยเต่าค่ะ
อื
เต่าเต่าที่เป็นสัตว์ไม่ใช่ปล่อยเต่าแบบ
นี้
นะนะูชิเนี่ยก็ชอบปล่อยเต่านะคะแต่เต่า
เนี่ยมันก็มีเยอะนะครูชิครูชิก็ต้องดูค่ะ
ค่ะถ้าไปทะเลก็ต้องปล่อยเต่าทะเลถ้าไปแม่
น้ำก็ต้องปล่อยเต่าที่แม่ปล่อยเต่าแม่น้ำ
อันนี้เป็นเต่าทะเลหรือเต่าแม่น้ำคะทำไม
ปากแหลมๆอันนิตภาพอ่ะอันนิตภาพค่ะูบีอ๋อ
มันอ่ะเอานี่แล้วกันใช่อันเนี้ยเต่าอ้า
อันเนี้ยเต่าบกเพราะมีขาอ่ะเดี๋ยวครูบี
ซูมให้ดูอันบนเนี่ยเต่าทะเลค่ะโอเต่าทะเล
เนี่ยเหมือนปลาเนาะเออไยน
ไม่มีเล็บอืมอ่ะข้างบนเนาะเต่าทะเลอันที่
2 ล่ะคะูชิเต่าบกค่ะอันนี้ปล่อยที่วัด
ได้อืนะอันที่ 3 หรอคะอันที่ 3 ก็เเต่าบก
ค่ะอือ๋อเป็นเต่าทั้ง 2 แล้วก็ 3 ก็คือ
เป็นเต่าที่อยู่ในน้ำจืดใช่่มยไม่ได้อยู่
ในทะเลใช่แต่รูปแรกเนี่ยเป็นเต่าทะเลเนาะ
แล้วกูชิไปปล่อยเต่าเนี่ยเราจะไปปล่อย
ปล่อยที่ทะเลทะเลเอาเต่าบกไปปล่อยที่ทะเล
ได้มั้ยไม่ได้อันนีู้ชิจะไม่ได้ทำบุญค่ะ
อันนี้ทำบาปอืมันตายไม่ดีจะตายค่ะมันจะ
ตายเอาค่ะนะคะแล้วก็เมื่อกี้กี้อ่าอืเอ่อ
เต่าบางตัวมันก็ไม่ได้ชอบอยู่น้ำอย่าง
เดียวนะอืเต่าที่ขายาวๆไอ้ตัวข้างล่างที่
ครูบีให้ดูอ่ะตัวนั้นเนี่ยครูบีต้องไป
ปล่อยในป่าอ้าเหรอคะที่มันแบบมีน้ำนนิด
หน่อยๆมันไม่ค่อยชอบน้ำค่ะแต่ไอ้ตัวตรง
กลางใช่แต่ไอ้ตัวตรงกลางเนี่ยค่ะมันมัน
อยู่น้ำจืดได้ค่ะปล่อยปอ๋ออันนี้ปล่อยใน
แม่น้ำได้ในบึงในคลองแต่อันนี้คือชอบอยู่
ในป่าอย่างเงี้รอคะมีต้นไม้คือมันมีน้ำ
ได้แต่น้ำใหญ่เยอะมีมันชอบอยู่บนบกอยู่
อยู่ตามินตามก้อนหินมากกว่าออ๋อคืออยู่ใน
น้ำก็ได้อยู่บนบกก็ได้มันก็ชอบทั้ง 2
อย่างอืใช่แต่มันอยู่แต่บางทีเนี่ยคนที่
ปล่อยมันไปปล่อยในน้ำในในแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยา
นี่มันลึกไปอืมมันลึกไปถ้าเกิดอ่าไอ้ตัว
ข้างล่างนี้ต้องปล่อยในที่ที่แบบน้ำไม่
ลึกน้ำตื้นๆอันนี้นะคะน้ำเนี่ยไม่ลึกมาก
นะคะใช่อืเนาออแปลว่าปล่อยสัตว์เนี่ยก็
ต้องเข้าใจว่าปล่อยที่ไหนอ่าเดี๋ยวปล่อย
ไปแล้วเต่าตายเนี่ยเราก็ไม่ได้ทำบุญนะคะ
อ่าเป็นว่าเอาเต่าไปฆ่านะคะก็จะไม่ดีเนาะ
ถูกต้องนะแล้วเต่าเนี่ยมีความหมายมั้ยครู
ชิปล่อยเต่าอุ๊ยอันนี้ครูชิชอบเพราะเต่า
เนี่ยไม่ได้อายุ 100 ปีนะอายุ 200 ปีบวกๆ
เพราะฉะนั้นถ้าอยากอายุยืนเหมือนเต่าก็
ต้องเอาเต่าไปปล่อยค่ะเพราะเราไม่กินเต่า
อยู่แล้วเอาเต่าไปไปปล่อยเนี่ยให้เรา
เนี่ยอายุ 100
ปีแต่ครูชิบอกว่าบางตัวเนี่ยเต่าอายุ 200
ปีใช่มั้ยคะเอโอเคมั้ยครูชิสวัสดีค่ะฟัน
วายบายหมดแล้วตาก็มองไม่เห็นแล้วใครอ่ะ
ใครหมาหาใครเอา 80 ปีก็พอมั้งูชิเออหรือ
ว่า 99 โอเคใช่มอ 99  200 เนี่ยน่าจะเดิน
ไม่ได้แล้วค่ะก็คือเต่าเอายุยืนไงเรา
ปล่อยเพื่อให้เราเนี่ยอายุยืนปกติเราอาจ
จะซัก 80 ออาจจะตายใช่มยเราก็อาจจะยืดไป
ถึง 99 อย่างที่
ครูบ 99 คนไทเลขสวยมั้ยคะ 99 อ่าเป็นเลข
โชคดีนะ 99 อายุ 99 กำลัง
ดีใช่ค่ะโอเคนะอันนี้ก็ปล่อยเต่าเนาะ
สำหรับอยากอายุยืนอายุนานๆนะคะก็มีความ
หมายเนาะอืออยากมีความสุขมั้ยคะอยากมีสิ
คะทุกคนก็อยากอยากมีความสุขเนี่ยไม่ใช่
ปล่อยเต่าไม่ใช่ปล่อยปลาค่ะต้องปล่อยหอย
อ๋อใช่ๆครูบีก็ได้ยินว่าคนไทยเนี่ยก็ชอบ
ไปเอาหอยเนี่ยไปปล่อยแต่ต้องเป็นหอยชนิด
อะไรคะูชิน้หอยที่อยู่แม่น้ำค่ะอืนะนะที่
ที่ครูบีเคยได้ยินเนี่ยเขาบอกว่าจะชื่อ
หอยขมใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะมันอยู่แในแม่น้ำได้
อื
นะขแงหอยนางลมหอยอันนี้อยู่ทะเล่ะอืก็จะ
เป็นหอยอันนี้นะคะอือหือแต่จริงๆแล้วหอย
ขมเนี่ยเราก็เอามาทำอาหารนะเอามาแกงเอามา
ลวกแล้วก็จจิ้มน้ำน้ำจิ้มเผ็ดๆอร่อยมากนะ
คะอ่าหอยขมอ้าทำไมทำไมเราปล่อยหอยขมแล้ว
เรามีความสุขก็เอาความขื่นขมทิ้งไปหมด
แล้วไงอืมเอาสิ่งที่ไม่ดีที่สิ่งที่เสีย
ใจเนี่ยทิ้งไปเอ้ยไม่ใช่ทิ้งปล่อยไปแล้ว
ปล่อยความขมขื่นอ้าวเอาความขมขื่นไปทิ้ง
แม่โขงอ่าเพราะว่าชื่อหอยขมอะไรที่มันขม
เี่มันเหมือนเรามีความทุกข์เราไม่มีความ
สุขไงบางคนอาจจะอกหักบางคนไม่มีงานทำบาง
คนเสียใจมีปัญหาใช่มั้ยอันนี้คือชีวิตนี่
มีแต่ความขมขื่นมีแต่ความทุกข์ไม่มีความ
สุขเลยเออพอเอาหอยขมไปปล่อยเนี่ยความ
ทุกข์ก็จะไปนะเราก็จะมีความสุขกลับมาออจะ
ได้มีความสุขเราก็จะเหลือแต่ความสุขแต่
ตอนเนี้ยเรากำลังหมดความสุขค่ะเ้าเพราะ
เพราะว่าเวลาเนี่ยมาขัดจังหวะเราค่ะเค้า
จะให้เราแบบหมดเวลาหมด
เวลาอ่ะไม่เป็นไรนะคะเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกัน
ใหม่เราก็จะได้มีความสุขอีกครั้งนะคะใน
ครั้งต่อไปเนาะครูชิวันนี้เราหมดเวลาแล้ว
อืเราก็มาคุยกันเกี่ยวกับเรื่องคนไทย
เนี่ยก็จะไปปล่อยสัตว์ต่างๆปล่อยปลาปล่อย
นกนะคะปล่อยเต่านะคะอ่าส่วนมากก็ในวัน
เกิดเนาะอืใช่ค่ะอนี้ก็เป็นความเชื่อของ
คนไทยนะค่ะวันนี้ก็ลาทุกคนไปก่อนนะคะแล้ว
ก็ขอบคุณครูชิมากไว้เจอกันใหม่สวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะพบกันใหม่ค่ะ